our next guest played for the notre dame
fighting option oh there he is julian
aguaro with the sack and the fumble and
tried to get to it you tried to get to
it but your teammate took it away from
you
uh and here he is at the scouting
combine with us live it's defensive
lineman and linebacker's day edge rusher
julian acquire julian it's great to see
you great to have you thank you it's
been a crazy week i think for everybody
but i can't imagine going through what
you guys go through where you just your
whole week right is planned out and you
just have to go wherever they say do you
feel like at any time your patience gets
a little bit tested by just all this got
to be here got to be here got to be
there no um going to notre dame uh
there's a lot demanded out of you um
there's no excuses for missing this
meeting missing anything academic
so i think just becoming here it's kind
of reminds me of notre dame you hold
yourself to a high standard got to be
there be on point every time
so i'm just grateful to be here it's a
great opportunity
the um the scouting combine eventually
is going to entail your workout
opportunity they're doing it night now
are you going to do everything
everything good to go i'm going to i'm
going to be benching um and i'll be
running your pro day okay oh so you're
deferring everything to pro day yes sir
is that injury reason is that just
personal preference personal preference
uh just want to make sure 100 i don't
want to give teams anything less than
that um i just want to give my best how
many teams have you talked to so far
uh i've had about seven formal
interviews we got 12 on tomorrow so
got a decent amount strangest question
you've been asked so far
i actually haven't been asked any
strange questions surprisingly i've been
looking forward to that one kind of
waiting for that one to happen but
nothing nothing crazy what what would
you ask you if you were the one doing
the interview
i don't know i'm not good at coming up
with questions but i like answering them
they're pretty i think it's a great way
to kind of get to know my get to know
get people to know me um
i don't know i don't know i think a lot
of people want to know who i am and i
have a brother's in the league and i
think i'm a little different from him so
i think it's a great way to show my
personality who julianna carr is yeah
your brother romeo is uh part of the nfl
now how much has that helped you prepare
for what's coming right it's been
awesome i mean he's a guy who went
undrafted coming out of his college
college career um just a path that he's
taken going into his fifth season um
playing with the lines next year um
he's taught me a lot um just work hard
and the sacrifices he's made to kind of
get to where he's at and how he has to
be consistent every day um being on
drafty you got to work a little harder
than the guys who got that first second
round pick so um just seeing the path
he's taking and how grateful he is be
where he's at and never taking anything
for granted and that really is a heck of
an accomplishment i mean you got 256
guys usually they're about to get
drafted and then you have this scrum of
other players who still want to play and
they have the dream and and to work and
work and work and to get the attention
of your coaches when the presumption is
the draft picks are going to get the job
to get a job as an undrafted player
really is impressive and it speaks to
his character and it's a good mentor for
you as you uh learn the ropes in the nfl
right yeah i think it's a great honor
kind of having his backbone to rely on
before i came out here i talked to him a
little bit and he texts me every day
kind of make sure i'm doing okay
so i'm just excited to be here really
when did you discover football
i actually discovered football i started
playing in eighth grade but my brothers
played it um when i was in maybe like
fifth sixth grade um i was more i was
playing tennis and soccer and all these
other sports um
grew up got to eighth grade and i was
like i would kind of be like my brother
being the younger guy of the house you
kind of look up to your older brothers
and i started playing football 8th grade
played safety
highlight of my career in 8th grade was
actually going to pick six ones because
my brother actually got cut from the 8th
grade team so going into high school um
played i wanted to play tight end my
defensive line my head coach in high
school looked at me and was like what's
your name he was like you're in a choir
right he was like no you're playing
defensive end because both my brothers
played defensive end at audrey kell so
just kind of cool to see the guys who
supported me and my head coach who had
the best interest for me and where i'm
at right now when did you first have an
inkling that you were going to have the
skills and abilities to play football at
a really high level right um i think
going into my
sophomore year i kind of started getting
more comfortable with my body
in high school i feel like i was really
fast i was dominating plays though i was
on jv i knew going into my junior year
i'd be taking over the game anytime soon
um so it's just a matter of time i think
just
eighth grade kind of being like a little
tryout season in the 9th grade being a
little warm up sophomore i started
feeling things out a little bit junior
year i really started feeling my body
and getting really loved getting to love
football honestly um started watching a
lot of a lot of it more watching my
brothers my brother being in college at
this point i was watching a lot of his
games and learning from him so it's cool
to have an older brother who's go who
goes through it and kind of learn from
his mistakes and try to do better but it
gives you the confidence you can do it
too i think confidence is such an
underrated part you have to believe you
can do it you have to have almost to the
point of delusional like i can do this
right and you have to have that mindset
in order to get the most out of your
physical abilities right
um
the uh
this concept of domination domination at
the high school level uh and we've seen
film from so many guys and it just
stands out you can tell the guys that
are gonna make it but when you get to
the college level it gets a little
tougher what was the transition like for
you to go from high school to college
where you got a lot of guys who were
dominant in high school right um in high
school i mean you go from being the best
player on the field
transitioning college my freshman year
actually went against guys like quinn
nelson michael gunji um sam us for all
those guys they were top 10 picks in nfl
draft two years ago um it's crazy to see
how far i've come my freshman year going
against those guys they definitely put
me on my butt a little bit um sophomore
year um i think it was spring ball
that's when i really started clicking
stuff i was going against mike and q and
i was beating him i was actually i was
like well i'm really going against these
guys every day and it was cool to look
back my freshman year when i was getting
tossed around by those guys i was little
i was thinking i was like 220 then so
they were they were doing that one arm
curling they were curling my weight
really so it's kind of cool to look back
and kind of see where i'm at right now
and uh four years ago um just how much
i've grown and learned much about
football and growing my body and kind of
the way i play and i think i just really
started
to feel myself and the dominance i knew
i could take over games whenever i
wanted to how hard was it for you to go
from 220 to 250
it wasn't really hard when i was younger
i actually didn't really feel like my
weight was it was hurting me in the game
i feel like i was still a dominant
player um fast physical
um but transitioning my junior year ever
out here in my ear all the time people
who wanted me gain weight so i was like
all right i'll get you give you what you
guys want we've seen highlights of
quentin nelson with the colts and some
of the things he can do so you've been
on the wrong end of some of those oh
yeah yeah
and mike i think there was one time in
spring ball um i was i was beating him
and mike i was getting one-on-one and
then i think one play they just kind of
like nah we're going to double team you
so they tossed me the ground so that was
a little humbling
i stopped talking after that one so um i
forgot to toss the ground but by then i
was like all right you guys got it yeah
i've never seen a big guy move like
quentin nelson yeah
what's it what's the experience like
when you're you're there across from him
or close to him and you see that blur
that he becomes right um so first of all
i think in the weight room um just
seeing him in spring ball the way he
worked um i wanted to be just like him
that's a guy kind of modeled my game
after from apart from afar you know he
was on offense i'm a defensive guy and
seeing the way he went about his
business how professional he was in the
weight room off the field on the field
everything he did his preparation he
literally like hit the wall like a solid
concrete wall before games and he's just
like a he's just a machine he likes all
he does was work his work ethic is
phenomenal and i wanted to be just like
him um
everything he did was just so unique and
i love just watching him taking notes
and just trying to pick his brain he was
actually one of my closest guys that i
hung out with a little bit back at
school when he was there um
it was great to learn from those guys as
a young kid would you rather be his
opponent or teammate at the next level
i think i think i'd rather get a little
redemption back at him again i still
have got that little sour taste in my
mouth him and mike got it after me a
little bit of the two which one would
you rather face first
uh mike being a tackle i'd probably go
against him um i could rush at three
tech two so i'll go against both of them
to be honest who's the guy when you get
onto a football field at the nfl level
you're gonna look out there and say oh
my gosh i can't believe i'm here on the
same field as this guy uh
maybe von miller uh vaughn miller tom
brady all those guys i remember my
brother when he first stacked tom brady
in the i think a preseason game or
something like that um
i think it hit him when he he got i
think he's stacked him like twice now um
so it's kind of cool to kind of grow up
and watch those guys when they're as
veterans um and then me being a rookie
uh transitioning nfl next year um it's
something i've been dreaming of dreaming
of my whole life
um just kind of crazy to see the path
i've been coming from lagos nigeria a
lot of guys don't really make it this
far or have the opportunity to be in my
position right now so i'm just grateful
to be here yeah walk me through the
timeline born in london and then you
went to nigeria yes sir uh well okay
take me from from london to now where
you've lived uh so i've live i was in
london born in london my mom was there
my sis my mom's sister um lives out
there um so i think my mom just kind of
wanted to have babies in different
countries my oldest brother were born in
america romeo was born in nigeria i was
born in london my sister was born in
nigeria um moved i lived in lagos
nigeria for eight years um when i was
eight years old moved to charlotte north
carolina i've lived here ever since i
actually went back for the first time in
nigeria this past summer
it's just kind of crazy to look back and
see where i was and um i mean i never
take things for granted i think it
really hit me
that i'm really here and the
opportunities i have in america i mean a
lot of there's a lot of nigerians who
could they come to america and really
take over notre dame or take over
the football game there's a lot of
nigerians in the nfl and everyone has
high things to speak about them
i think it's coming to come to show by
the character of nigeria nigerians and
how they're brought up and raised and
how humble they are how hard working
they are and the kind of people they
people they are in the future it's a
great story and we're really proud of
what you've done and we're impressed by
what you've done and we wish you all the
best as you move forward in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports